Todd is on the air Todd is from New
Jersey once I want to call and talk to
you
talk to you your buddy Pete
Pete well I don't want to uh come off
with a big head here but everyone's
looking at me going you predicted this
on the air Howard yeah let me uh play
this for you I was thinking um Pete
Davidson could go out with Emily
Ratajkowski that that beauty now there
you go there's another woman she was
just here of not too long ago talking
about her book and now she's getting a
divorce that's right
so that would be a good match up there I
think it's [ __ ] great first of all I
call it I just laughed because Pete
after uh Kim Kardashian
wasn't gonna date any more famous women
this dude is living the dream and you
know you could get a little bit jealous
and go jeez I mean why him now he's a
funny dude he's famous he's Rich he's
got big dick energy everyone knows about
his big [ __ ] why does he keep saying I'm
gonna stop doing this famous women are
exciting
nobody's asking Pete to stop dating
famous women he keeps volunteering well
he's trying it you know you ever talk to
a drug addict and he keeps saying I'm
gonna quit these drugs but they can't do
it famous women are like a drug but she
is a great Beauty but at some point if
he [ __ ] so many women
and you know so many famous women he's
going to start to get the reputation
that this guy just goes like he's like a
bee he pollinates and then goes
pollinates and then goes so he's got to
pull off the Leo DiCaprio thing you
don't listen Leo states with each of
these girls two years
that's his move and you got to respect
it he puts him to you you get right you
get two years from 22 to 24 you get to
be with Leonardo DiCaprio so he puts it
you know he makes you believe you're the
one all right Pete was with Kim
Kardashian for nine months okay but he
should have spent two years long-term
relationship for Pete well that's what
I'm saying you don't want to become the
guy who just [ __ ] celebrity girls so
he's got to be careful but he's on a
terrific role I say right on
foreign